[Musique]
et j'accueille karolinska au bon soir
bonsoir
vous êtes candidate à montigny le
bretonneux sur les listes mm pour
alternative ini monteyne écologique et
citoyenne la tête de liste et vivien
gasc actuel conseiller municipal
d'opposition dans la commune mais c'est
bien un duo vous composer avec lui que
vous souhaitez mettre en avant pourquoi
mais la liste m c'est un collectif qui
existe depuis le début de l'année
dernière et depuis le mois de septembre
en oeuvre ensemble on fait les
assemblées citoyennes pour élaborer le
programme et il ne semblait pas
approprié d'avoir une seule personne qui
représentait tout le collectif
donc on a fait le choix d'un binôme et
donc c'est le binôme qui est mis en
avant sur toute la communication qui est
là pour présenter le programme aux
habitants tout le collectif est avec
nous pour présenter le programme et
c'est vraiment cette force là qu'on a
voulu mettre en avant et je rectifie
juste pardon parce que j'ai dit que
c'était écologique et citoyenne c'est
écologique et solidaire m voilà dans
cette liste mais du coup si vous êtes
élu y aura bien un seul maire qui sera
en poste
alors après il y aura un seul maire en
poste mais notre objectif c'est que le
premier adjoint
la première adjointe en l'occurrence
soit autant investi dans le rôle que le
maire qui suivent les dossiers soient
suivies à deux et qu'on puisse
prendre le rôle l'un de l'autre il y en
a toujours un qui a la délégation qui
est la responsabilité mais après sur des
dossiers on peut partager la responsable
des fonctions partager le temps surtout
qui est que ce soit pas une seule
personne qui gère la ville comme c'est
le cas un peu partout alors votre liste
aurait pu s'allier à une autre menée par
pierre déjean une candidature qui
revendiquait à gauche pourquoi les
discussions n'ont pas abouti avec pierre
des gens ça n'a pas abouti mascella la
vision de ce qu'on a envie de faire
voyez nous c'est un collectif qui
fonctionne n'est pas forcément à une
seule personne et ça ça finalement pas
coller on peut le regretter
parce que nos idées
ce sont parfois les mêmes mais vraiment
sur le côté démocratie participative
on va beaucoup plus loin sur la
transition écologique on est beaucoup
plus innovant en fait et ça ça n'a pas
marché pour ms que la sensibilité est
aussi à gauche c'est une candidature
plurielle finalement c'est une
candidature plurielle mais on se
revendique pas de d'être à gauche comme
à droite on est on est plus à l'heure où
il faut s'opposer
il faut s'unir pour construire la ville
de demain il ya beaucoup d'urgences
il ya des crises climatiques et crise
sociale et crise économique il faut
qu'on aille qu'on avance qu'on aille de
l'avant et qu'on passe au delà de ces
idées de parti politique et donc nous on
est sans étiquette
on a des valeurs qui sont l'écologie la
démocratie participative la solidarité
qui se retrouve dans ses valeurs peut
nous rejoindre pour travailler alors le
programme parlons-en il a été construit
après une phase de concertation vous
avez rencontré lésigny mon temps pour
construire vos priorités pour passer ça
donc depuis le mois de septembre
on a fait des ateliers porteurs de
paroles où on était dans les places de
montigny dans les quartiers pour
discuter avec les gens savoir quelles
étaient leurs ressentis de la ville on a
construit fait des attaques version gay
citoyenne on en a fait quatre pour
construire ce programme en fait on a eu
des idées les citoyens en apporte
d'autres et ensemble qu'est ce qu'on
priorise qu'est ce qui est important qu
est-ce qui est pas important sur quoi la
mairie peut agir c'est tout ça qui s'est
fait ensemble et du coup on a plus de
100 propositions pour
dynamiser la ville détaillé ses 100
propositions en tout cas on va parler de
trois axes prioritaires
vous parliez tout à l'heure de la
démocratie participative c'est
d'ailleurs l'une de ses trois priorités
que vous exposez pour le programme
comment la mettre en place
à montigny le bretonneux qu'est ce que
vous entendez par démocratie
participative plus mais pour nous la
démocratie participative c'est que les
citoyens puissent s'impliquer dans la
vie de la commune pas juste en allant
choisir leurs élus
mais en étant force de proposition on va
mettre en place des groupes d'action
projet donc quand on fait un projet on
va appeler les habitants
on va faire intervenir des experts faire
tout un groupe qui fonctionne qui
communiquent qui co construit le projet
c'est pas la mairie qui vient qui va
dire j'impose ça je veux faire ça non
les habitants
c'est quoi votre ressenti nous refaire
ce projet là comment vous voyez nous on
a nos exigences d'éthique d'écologie de
solidarité qui viennent avec
mais comment on peut faire que tout ça
fonctionne ensemble se veut dire aussi
que les projets iront forcément moins
vite ou au contraire ils seront plus
réfléchi mais ils vont forcément être
plus réfléchi
est-ce que ça va aller moins vite pas
forcément parce que le temps de
conception de co construction va être
plus long mais du coup le projet sera
bien pensée on n'aura plus besoin de
faire des réajustements à la fin qui
allonge les projets alors une autre
priorité pardon c'est la transition
écologique
comment à l'échelle d'une commune on
peut mettre en place des actions
justement en faveur de cette transition
écologique médias il ya énormément de
choses à faire
déjà la mairie se doit d'être exemplaire
on veut que les bâtiments soient
vraiment économes en énergie qui soit
mieux isolés que l'électricité soit soit
mieux penser qu'ils soient producteurs
d'énergie solaire aussi pourquoi pas
donc c'est un axe après c'est aussi
quand on est dans nos services ben
comment on peut être tendre vers le zéro
déchet par exemple produire moins de
déchets
les véhicules de la flotte de la mairie
comment on peut les repenser et ce qu'on
peut mettre par exemple des trottinettes
électriques quand on veut se déplacer
d'une école à une autre
au lieu de prendre forcément une voiture
c'est de repenser un peu tout ce que
fait la mairie pour voir comment on peut
réduire l'empreinte carbone de la vie
plusieurs pistes évoquées alors la
dernière priorité c'est la solidarité le
vivre ensemble quel type de proposition
vous pouvez faire sur sur cet axe là sur
la solidarité ça nous tient beaucoup à
coeur de développer l'insertion par
exemple que dans les antres pour les
entreprises qui sont sollicités par la
mairie pour intervenir sur tous les
projets on met une clause d'insertion
dans les marchés publics de même pour
remettre des clauses écologique il faut
qu'il y ait une clause d'insertion
alors ces élections municipales aussi je
le précise il aura également des
élections communautaire en élire nos
conseillers municipaux mais aussi les
ailes et conseiller communautaire votre
regard sur le travail les liens entre
montigny le bretonneux et
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines où montigny-le-bretonneux qui
est forcément une ville centrale dans
cette agglomération il ya notamment ce
projet d'hyper centre qui est en tout
cas l'actualité du moment quel est le
regard vous portez
mais ce travail ben en tant que
citoyenne je participe à la concertation
suis allé aux ateliers il y en a fin
février
moi je trouve ça génial de pouvoir
mettre les habitants au coeur de la
concertation au coeur de la conception
après il faut voir nous ce qu'on
aimerait c'est que le projet puisse
entrer dans 21e siècle on parle vraiment
d'écologie mais que ce soit à la base ou
par les circulations douces ont réfléchi
aux matériaux qu'on utilise
on va repenser toutes les circulations
voiture on va voir quels sont les usages
aussi de la ville parce que c'est un
quartier que je pratique parce que c'est
le mien où on n'a pas de lieu de vie
donc c'est pour nous c'est fondamental
que ce soit fait vraiment concertation
avec les habitants et qu'on remette de
la verdure qu'on remette du lien que
tout ça fonctionne ensemble
après si justin pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas l'hyper centre que il
s'agit du quartier 1 qui est autour de
la gare sncf de saint quentin en
yvelines
une dernière question vos prochains
rendez vous de campagne mais ce soir on
a une réunion publique ce mercredi soir
à la maison de quartier louis jouvet
après c'est le 27 février
on serait en réunion publique à la
maison de quartier malraux et le 10 mars
à la salle jacques brel
merci karolinska aux candidates de la
liste m
alternative iny monteyne écologique et
solidaire et je précise qu à montigny le
bretonneux deux autres listes sont
également candidates celle menée par
pierre déjean montini solidarité 2020 et
la liste également de lorrains mais
requiert candidat de la majorité
sortante
iny monteyne